هذه الصوره التقطت في الخامس من ديسمبر
كانون الاول الجاري بقطر بعد تاهلهم الى
الدوري ربع النهائي من كاس العالم لكره
القدم رفع لاعب البرازيل هذه اللافته
تكريما للعب دوليه جوهره التاريخ الكروي
البرازيلي والذي تدهورت صحته انذاك بشكل
كبير
صور توليه زينت واجهات عدد من البنايات
الشاهقه في الدوحه وقد عبر حينها اللاعب
الشهير عن شكره لمنظم البطوله عن هذه
اللفته وعن امتنانه لكل من ينشغلون بصحته
حسب كلماته
في الثامن عشر من ديسمبر كان يشاهد على
فراش المرض المباراه النهائيه بين فرنسا
والارجنتين وقد سرع حينها الى تهنئه كل من
ليونيل ميسي وكليون مبابي اللذين صنع
ملحمه كرويه خلال النهائي بعد ان شخص
الاطباء سرطان القولون لديه في سبتمبر من
عام 2021 وضع تحت مراقبه طبيه دائمه قبل
ان يدخل المستشفى في نهايه نوفمبر الماضي
ومع تدهورته قبل الاطباء تشاما حيل فرص تع
فيه
هو كما تضرع الملايين للسماء في الارجنتين
وفي امريكا الجنوبيه وفي انحاء العالم من
اجل نجاه النجم الراحل دييغو مارادونا في
نوفمبر من عام 2020 لم يصمود بولي كذلك
ورائه اسطوره تعبر ذاكره الملاعب
وشغف الاجيال
[موسيقى]